in the seaside village of Novartis in
the Philippines Erik Jaramillo has been
behaving erratically for months people
here believe that his soul is under
siege by none other than the devil
himself the Philippines is home to over
60 million Catholics for most Filipinos
their concept of evil is based on the
Christian belief in the devil Eric's
mother Elena her Ammiano
fears for her son's soul every night she
reads the Bible and prays for him often
that's when the trouble starts tonight a
reading from Scripture triggers
something in Erik his handshake his eyes
rolled back in his head his reaction
changes sometimes I'm afraid
Elena believes evil has descended upon
her son he claims not to remember what
happens during his attacks by Catholic
tradition only priests can conduct
exorcisms but one of Manila's most
famous exorcists is a former Catholic
who offers his services for free he'll
see hundreds of patients in a day
they call him ha among convinced that
evil spirits possess her son Elena seeks
help from Kali monk to purge the spirit
The Exorcist must first identify it
we'll try to find out who's possessing
you okay
he places feathers between Erik's toes
in a belief that they will invoke the
spirit Satan is just one possible source
of the evil in Erik
before Filipinos adopted Christianity
they believed in a whole host of evil
spirits to this day demons evil dwarves
and trolls are blamed for a variety of
maladies
but the exorcist suspects that this time
the devil himself is involved first time
this boy immediately knew this wasn't an
ordinary case of possession I touched
the feet he fell to shiver I knew it was
a bad one ha
among tries to communicate with the
spirit whoever you are I just want to
speak with you I wish you no harm
to the Exorcist it appears that the
Spirit has seized control he demands
answers why are you in the child go
ahead speak what is the reason this is
something you need from him
in a state of possession eric begins to
scribble it's a disturbing message
garbled words about darkness and the
devil for two days just go to church so
that your prayer comes from your heart
two days have passed Eric and Alayna
returned to the exorcists Kyle
among begins again by placing the
feathers between Eric's toes he tries to
contact the spirit does that hurt
nothing ha Eamon finds nothing wrong
he believes the powerful combination of
the earlier exorcism and Alana's prayers
have vanquished the evil spirit they
won't come back
it's over you've gotten through it Elena
is relieved Eric seems better but to be
sure she seeks further guidance from her
priest father Rick has performed 9
exorcism sanctioned by the church but
he's skeptical whether Eric was really
possessed within minutes the priest
uncovers another possible reason Eric's
father died several months ago and Eric
only heard about it 3 months later the
attack started around the same time
father Rick suspects eric has been
suffering from psychological trauma the
priest thinks the exorcism might have
made the attacks worse by convincing
Eric that his spirit was to blame
but kah among still believes he saved
the boy he says the church disapproves
of his work because he's not a priest
what can I say to people let's say this
is taboo that is your opinion I'm only
doing this to help people do it what the
hell as long as thousands of people in
Manila continue to believe in his powers
kha Iman will continue to battle evil
spirits free of charge